welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Elizabeth wood a professor of
political science at Yale University
professor woods current research focuses
on sexual violence during war she is the
author of insurgent collective action
and civil war in El Salvador and forging
democracy from below insurgent
transitions in South Africa and El
Salvador as well as various scholarly
articles today we'll talk with Professor
wood about two of her recently published
works on sexual violence during war
welcome professor wood thanks very much
for having me you have researched sexual
violence occurring in wars throughout
the world what is your most important
finding yes I visited Sri Lanka Israel
Palestine South Africa Peru Colombia all
for this project on wartime sexual
violence the most important finding for
me was also the most surprising finding
in my work on this subject so far and
that is that there are armed groups that
don't engage in widespread sexual
violence indeed there are some conflicts
where neither party to the conflict
engages in sexual violence so there's
really an absence of sexual violence in
some conflicts why do you think that is
can you cite some examples sure there
various reasons why an armed group might
not engage in sexual violence so for
example the leadership of a group might
decide it is against their strategic
interests or against their normative
beliefs if they're combatants engage in
sexual violence there might be a number
of reasons for example they might depend
on civilians for high-quality
intelligence and might reason that if
they engage in widespread sexual
violence against those civilians
civilians will stop providing such
intelligence but whether or not that
message gets down to the combatants on
the ground of course depends on the
quality of the
pterri hierarchy so that's another
condition for an absence of sexual
violence but there may also be on the
ground dynamics going on in other cases
so for example if combatants believe for
example for religious really reasons
that engaging in sexual violence across
some ethnic cleavage would be polluting
to themselves then they may not engage
in sexual violence for that reason I say
why is it important to study sexual
violence during wartime sexual violence
is a form of violence against some of
the most vulnerable populations in war
zones
the most typical case of sexual violence
is rape of girls and women's sometimes
repeated over an extended period of time
and those populations are often
defenseless often extremely poor often
with very few resources to try to
overcome this horrible event and sexual
violence may have very long run
consequences not just for the victims of
sexual violence but for the social
fabric of communities but if I'm right
that sexual violence varies this the way
that I described that there are armed
groups that do not engage in sexual
violence it's also very important that
we document and analyze that because
that fact if I'm right has important
policy implications why because if there
are armed groups that don't engage in
sexual violence that means that
leadership's
if they really want to can prohibit
sexual violence and therefore we have a
position we have evidence against this
idea that sexual violence is endemic
during war it's just part of the horrors
of war and therefore we have more
grounds to hold responsible those groups
that do engage in sexual violence okay
so in doing your research you have found
variations in the types of sexual
violence from war to war can you cite
some specific examples sure
so the type of sexual violence in some
settings is the rape for example in an
afternoon of the girls and women in some
village for example but it may also take
the form of sexual slavery where those
girls and women may be taken essentially
as slave by an armed group and held
forcibly sometimes for not just months
but years sometimes it takes the form of
sexual torture that is torture that has
various sexual dimensions and that is
actually quite common against men and
boys as well as against girls and women
the I should note also that who carries
out sexual violence varies across these
conflicts in some conflicts it's really
agents of the state that engage in
widespread sexual violence but in other
settings it's non-state groups that do
so and let me mention two more
particular patterns that are maybe not
widely understood one is that the
prevalence of gang rape in war is much
much higher than gang rape during
peacetime and also shockingly I think to
many people women engage in sexual
violence as well in some settings it's
not just men Wow can you I'm sitting
here wondering if there are any
particular countries that you have found
to be particularly brutal in terms of
evidence of sexual violence
I think the countries that are most
brutal in terms of the patterns of
sexual violence are countries that I
have not visited so among contemporary
conflicts I think I would rank probably
above all the rest the the Democratic
Republic of the Congo
in the eastern part of that country
there are ongoing patterns of conflict
that include a very high level of sexual
violence
and that is on a scale that we see very
rarely also in Darfur there's been a
very high level of sexual violence so
those are two conflicts that I'm relying
on my colleagues in the community of
nongovernmental organizations and
international organizations who document
that violence I'm relying on their data
and documents to understand what's going
on there let's talk a little bit about
your methodology because I imagine that
it's very difficult to gather data to
analyze this particular type of violence
tell me about your methodology you're
absolutely right it's one of the most
difficult things to document in the
social sciences and I use essentially
two methods the first method is that I
rely on nongovernmental organizations
government agencies international
organizations to document the patterns
of sexual violence I don't try to do
that myself and the kinds of data that
have been gathered essentially are of
two types one is eyewitness reports
sometimes from victims sometimes from
people who witnessed sexual violence and
also in some settings we have medical
reports or medical surveys the of course
the there are many risks here to victims
of sexual violence additional risks in
many settings of sexual violence report
what happened to them they may be either
stigmatized by their own community or
they may be targeted by armed groups
still in the area
indeed even witnesses to sexual violence
if they talk run some risk and moreover
in many cultural settings victims of
sexual violence be they women who've
suffered rape or gang rape or girls
particularly or be they boys or men who
have suffered sexual torture it is
extremely difficult in many settings for
them to talk about their experience
and indeed it seems that some victims of
sexual violence may become reach Rama
ties through the retelling of what
happened to them the conditions for
doing ethical research through
interviews with witnesses and victims of
sexual violence are I think very narrow
so I don't in fact myself
interview victims of sexual violence I
rely on the data and documents gathered
by others in addition to gathering the
data and documents from these other
organizations I also interview their
staff members extensively in these
various countries the other method that
I use is to study the internal dynamics
of the armed group so I gather again all
the data and documents analyses that I
can of the armed groups that I'm looking
at but ideally at the heart of what I'm
doing is interviewing former combatants
about how they were recruited how are
they trained how was discipline within
the group carried out in particular if
someone in their small unit engaged in
violence against civilians was that
promoted was it punished was it ignored
and so on thank you very much for
sharing some of your research with us
today thanks Marilyn it's been a
pleasure for more information about
Professor wood and her work please visit
our website at Yale edu backslash
Macmillan report be sure to join us
again for another episode of the
Macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Center for International and
area studies at Yale
you